welcome back to the big Sunday show
illogical coveted vaccine mandates still
affecting the Sports World unvaccinated
tennis Superstar Novak
Djokovic denied entry to the U.S open
which officially gets underway tomorrow
meanwhile Green Bay Packers quarterback
and I know this guy Aaron Rodgers
blasting the NFL for trying to weed out
unvaccinated players such as himself
last season Rogers has an allergy to an
ingredient in the covid vaccine and he
explained the chain of events which led
to his vilification on Joe Rogan's
podcast
they were doing this I called it a Witch
Hunt you know where they were asking
every single player are you vaccinated
and I had come to conclusion I'm going
to say I've been immunized that's when
the storm hit because now I'm a liar the
attempted takedown of
me and you know my word and my Integrity
began
Katie when it comes to specimens of uh
physical Excellence yeah are you gonna
take your cues from Aaron Rodgers or
Anthony fauci you know Aaron Rodgers
talked about this covid police who came
in you know the stooge that walked in in
a suit to sit him down to lecture him
about how this was really important for
his health Aaron Rodgers is one of the
healthiest human beings in the entire
world Djokovic has not been allowed in
the United States to play in the open
another one of the most healthy people
in the world and so for him to have a
bureaucrat walk in and say I think I
need to talk to you about what you
should do with your body is absolutely
ridiculous and the broader picture of
this was you know President Biden saying
this was the pandemic of the
unvaccinated when we started to learn
that actually vaccinated people were
getting it and spreading it to other
people and the way that the unvaccinated
were vilified run out of society not
allowed to go to restaurants they lost
their jobs the fact that doctors and
nurses firefighters police were on the
front lines of covid at the beginning
were then fired for not wanting to give
give up their own bodily autonomy was
anti-American it's completely wrong and
the idea that people still got away with
it and the fact that it continued even
though we had the data about the vaccine
we had the data about who was affected
who was most likely to die or have
serious illness and the idea that DC
bureaucrats in Washington like Anthony
fauci and people at the CDC couldn't
just say they were wrong for the sake of
their egos to continue to run Americans
out of society was completely disgusting
and Despicable and there's been no
accountability for it at all so in other
words Aaron Rodgers could bench press
Anthony fauci and probably you probably
could yeah
um you know it is kind of amazing to
listen to Aaron Rodgers admit that he
was sort of misleaded used misleading
language uh I'm I keep waiting for
anyone in Washington to admit that they
lied for years about this but Rachel
listen to this uh listen to the sound
bite from the the uh podcast with Aaron
Rodgers
we're going to Virtue signal to say look
how righteous our league is we have 95
percent compliance yes with the vaccine
compliance and if you don't we're going
to send a stooge to your team to show
you graphs of your vaccination
percentage of your team compared to the
rest of the league which actually
happened really yeah yeah
horrifying is that yeah so the
government is putting pressure on the
NFL league and then the NFL is putting
the pressure on the players here we're
in this crazy moment and you described
it well uh Katie but this is a moment
where people need to be strong and
people who have platforms and money and
the ability like Aaron Rodgers to make
statements I wish he would have made a
stronger statement there are lots of
little people waitresses and and
teachers and nurses and firemen who got
fired and there were a lot of players in
his own League who didn't have the power
he had I admire him for not taking the
vaccine I was one of those people I was
also ashamed for making that decision
for myself but I wish that he wouldn't
have done this little cute by half I was
immunized he should have stood up for
body autonomy for our rights our
religious liberty or whatever our health
reasons were for not taking it he was
somebody who could have really been a
voice and I think
dejokovic really did do that and I
admire him a lot for that you know he
didn't mince words you know Trace I
can't help but be a bit conspiratorial
here uh moderna is one of the uh
sponsors of the U.S open does that kind
of worry you a little bit I mean come on
you can't tell me that you're going to
allow thousands of fans that do not have
to be vaccinated into watch these
players right they're gonna sit cheek to
jail they don't have to be vaccinated
and the number one player in the world
who's had covet twice by the way has to
be vaccinated come on he's had it twice
it's no worries we know as Katie said it
doesn't stop you from getting it doesn't
stop you from spreading it it might stop
you from dying but Novak Djokovic is not
worried about his health and neither
should the tennis officials I just want
to say lastly thank goodness it's no
longer a pandemic of the unvaccinated it
is now a pandemic of the semi-fascist
yeah right
next vilification our adversary
extremists hi winner Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now